à vos fiançailles les amoureux vous êtes
trop mignon
[Musique]
celle de mes fantasmes de star je
m'attendais à quelqu'un qui a une vraie
personnalité je crois qu'on a pas le
même concept de liste tous les deux
tu pourrais aller lui parler qu'est-ce
que je peux bien lui raconter
où est-ce que vous allez
foutu mon fiancé s'est tapé Kenzi Scott
maintenant il faut savoir quelle est la
prochaine étape j'ai toujours privilégié
mon travail ou bien mat bah maintenant
peut-être qu'il est temps de penser à
moi tu vois je vais me taper une
célébrité de ma liste
on touche le fond c'est vraiment purée
c'est pour ça qu'on a besoin d'un plan B
c'est fiable et d'abord qu'est-ce que tu
vas lui dire je manipule les mots comme
personne acceptes-tu cette rose c'est
une pâquerette
merci mais non merci c'est vrai que tu
manipules les mots comme personne
prenez-le pour ce que ça vaut je crois
sincèrement que vous aviez une chance
on s'entend bien tous les deux ici
il me reste quatre noms sur ma liste on
devrait être méticuleuse regarde Oscar
Isaac a gagné un hashtag cours de vélo
fitness
et en plus vous ne bougez même pas les
jambes
[Musique]
tout le monde fantasme un peu sur l'idée
de passer une nuit avec une célébrité
mais plus enivrant des fantasmes c'est
de trouver la personne avec qui
[Musique]
bah c'est toute sa vie
amoureuse vraiment hallucinant ta vie